wir schauen live nach edinburgh dort
gleich ein großer gottesdienst zu ehren
der verstorbenen queen man hat sich dort
bereits aufgereiht king charles ist
bereits eingetroffene mit camilla beide
dort werden der queen ein letztes geleit
geben an diesem tag jetzt in schottland
auch dabei prinzessin und prinz andrew
wir begleiten live diese zeremonie hier
denn man könnte fast denken via family
das passt plötzlich wieder auf die
britische königsfamilie nach all den
streitereien den skandalen jetzt der
stunde der trauer um die queen da gibt
sich die familie jetzt auch ganz vereint
und auch ein außenseiter ist dazu
gestoßenen prinz harry und hier sehen
wir eine nachricht von ihm erst jetzt
zurück in england und hat ein
gefühlvolles statement heute
veröffentlicht schauen wir anderen
schreibt er unter anderem grenier the
grateful to me ich werde dir für immer
dankbar sein ganz persönliche worte die
er in diesem statement findet prinz
harry dass er heute veröffentlicht hat
er dort noch mal seine großmutter die
majestät die königin aber sie feiern und
natürlich auch ihren verlust betrauern
das schreibt er darin in diesem
statement bedankt sich auch noch mal
dass sie denn so sehr in die familie
aufgenommen hat und spricht davon dass
sie für viele menschen ein kompass war
wurde weltweit bewundert und respektiert
zuschreibt zu harry und bedankt sich bei
seiner großmutter wenn wir hier live die
bilder sehen jetzt gerade in edinburgh
ein bewegender moment in gab es schon
heute mitglieder des parlaments die
singen god save the queen schon wir in
diese bilder noch einmal rein
[Musik]
da sehen wir einen sichtlich bewegt
boris johnson ex premier der dort aus
vollem herzen mit sinkt aber wir sehen
auch schon sichtlich bewegten könig
tränen in den augen von charles das hört
er kann also nicht nur steif royal
äckern auch emotional er kann auch
menschlich eine wichtige eigenschaft für
einen könig und dieser moment er hat
ihnen dann doch schauen wir noch mal ins
gesicht
fast zu tränen gerührt
gehen wir nach edinburgh seit den frühen
morgenstunden waren die menschen dort
aus um ihrer queen einen letzten gruß zu
schicken um abschied zu nehmen und
mittendrin ist meine kolleginnen keira
ortmann kira wie wird die queen heute
verabschiedet wir sehen auf den straßen
ist es von stunde zu stunde voller und
voller geworden
ja absolut ich muss hier jetzt gerade
mal immer mit der kamera ein bisschen
hantieren ich bin nämlich gerade auf den
schultern von meinem kameramann damit
ich euch mal einmal einen überblick
geben kann die straße hier ist so
unfassbar folge sind so unfassbar viele
menschen ihr seht es hier das ist eben
die straße an der jetzt gleich der sagt
der queen entlang gefahren wird hier
diese ganze straße lang angeführt von
king charles und seiner frau camilla und
auch eben ihr habt es gesagt unter
anderem prinz andrew und prinzessinnen
sind dabei und hier ihr seht es ist
einfach unfassbar voll wir sind
unfassbar viele menschen alle sind ganz
aufgeregt schon und stehen hier wirklich
also ich glaube es sind mehr als 20
reihen pro seite an menschen die hierher
gekommen sind und ich schätze auch mal
die hinteren reihen die werden gar nicht
so viel sehen aber ich habe gerade schon
mit ein paar leuten gesprochen die haben
gesagt dabei sein ist tatsächlich in
diesem moment einfach alles und diese
atmosphäre hier vor ort zu spüren ich
drehe immer die kamera vorsichtig wieder
diese atmosphäre hier vor ort zu spüren
ist tatsächlich etwas ganz besonderes
und in wenigen wie nun ist es dann
soweit also um genau halt es geht es los
dort hinten am palast palace of
holyroodhouse und dann geht es hier
rüber und jetzt dreht die kamera nochmal
einmal dort vorne ist nämlich dann die
kirche in die die queen dann gebracht
wird dort wird er sagt dann zu 24
stunden für die öffentlichkeit auch
zugänglich sein dass die menschen die
hier sind werden sich wahrscheinlich
alle dort anstellen um sich auch noch
einmal persönlich dann von der queen zu
verabschieden
wahnsinn wie lang ist diese strecke dort
kira man sieht wirklich nur menschen
über menschen über menschen bei dir dort
im hintergrund so wie lange wird die
queen für all die menschen die jetzt
vielleicht nicht noch zeit hatten sich
stundenlang dann an der kirche
anzustellen überhaupt zu sehen sein
insgesamt geht diese strecke ungefähr
eine halbe stunde also in der kirche
sollen sie gegen 16 uhr deutscher zeit
daneben ankommen und dort wird dann ja
auch der große gottesdienst stattfinden
und ja insgesamt geht dementsprechend
diese route eine weile die reue main
heißt es hier im büro und ja viele
menschen wie gesagt werden die queen
dort
danach noch besuchen wollen ich habe
hier schon gerade unter anderem neben
mir sind auch ist eine kleine familie
hier die sind mit fünf kindern angereist
heute morgen dreieinhalb stunden um
überhaupt nur hier dabei zu sein und sie
haben auch vor sich dann nachher noch
dort anzustellen aber die leute rechnen
damit dass es wirklich dass sie sich da
teilweise 20 stundenlang anstellen
müssen um überhaupt in die nähe des
sargs kommen zu können in westminster
abbey dort wird dieses ja auch noch mal
die möglichkeit geben wenn die queen
dann nach london gefahren wird er sagte
klien dort wird schon erwartet dass die
leute da über 24 stunden anstehen müssen
um einmal dem sack eben ganz nahe zu
sein wenn du sprichst der tiere kennen
wir hier im studio live die bilder von
hollywood aus verfolgen dort scheint
sich die prozession jetzt auch in
bewegung zu setzen wir hören ein
dudelsack spielen wir sehen wie dort das
schloss verlassen hört irgendwann hat
man auch gesehen steht eine auto bereit
hier ist er jetzt auch zu erkennen der
sarg der queen der herausgetragen wird
geschmückt mit weißen blumen
und dann hört im hintergrund es sind
tausende abertausende menschen dort
jetzt
den straßen vermitteln mit diesen
wegen
das live mitzuerleben den sie auch zwei
verleben die verstorbene queen 70 jahre
was sie auf den thron
eine beliebte frau und immer wieder
darüber diskutiert wird was man
überhaupt machen bedeutet die für viele
so seite ist denke ich ein kompass
god save the queen
das jetzt save the king heißt wird ihr
seid jetzt
zum wagen wird
es wird gleich dann eine prozession
beginnen ihr seht will king charles
gefällt sein schwieriger tag auch für
ihn fahren haben wir gesehen mit tränen
in den augen tränen als zum ersten mal
das parlament für ihn god save beginn
sang tränen mit sicherheit um seine sehr
geliebte mutter
aber sicherlich auch tränen
des respekts vor diesem beamte ist dass
er jetzt antritt sehr lange hat er
gewartet hatte in einer art
freiheitsgrad hat sich auch für princess
dem jetzt king charles welt geworden ist
das leben dramatisch verändert ihm
können wir hier ins gesicht schauen
während der sarg seiner geliebten mutter
ins auto gebracht wird
sieht man da atmet man atmet er noch mal
richtig durch
und jetzt startet dann gleich eine
halbstündige prozession dort durch die
innenstadt von edinburgh
dann wird der sarg dort nochmal in einer
kathedrale aufgebahrt und 24 stunden
haben die schottinnen und schotten dann
zeit sich von ihrer queen von ihrer
königin lisa beste der zweiten zu
verabschieden bevor dann der sarg nach
london gebracht wird 19 september die
große beerdigung
jetzt aber startet erst mal die
prozession hierdurch edinburgh
zehntausende menschen derzeit auf der
straße fahren dort teilweise seit den
frühen morgenstunden aus unserer
reporterin kira ordnern konnte uns das
berichten es wird viele menschen
familien auch jetzt noch weinen um ihre
queen und diesen
historischen und auch emotionale moment
nicht verpassen wollen
er sagt der queen wurde jetzt ins auto
gebracht
gleich wird sie dann dort starten die
prozessionen einmal durch die stadt
circa eine halbe stunde lang
und schottland in edinburgh sie war
verstorben in schottland auf ihrem
landsitz schloss
sie eigentlich ein ort der schönen
erinnerungen jedes jahr als sie dort bis
zum oktober traditionell ihre
sommerfrische verbracht viele ausritte
barbecues standen dort auf dem programm
ist war sie ein ort der unbeschwertheit
in dem sie jetzt auch ihre letzte ruhe
gefunden hat
dann macht sich dort jetzt bereit mit
großen ehren würden das auto zu
begleiten der kofferraum schließt sich
dort und für uns begleitet diese
prozession meine kollegen vor ort haben
ist jetzt dort wo viele tausende
menschen ihrer darauf warten es ist
außerdem vorbeifährt um noch einmal der
queen die letzte ehre zu erweisen
ganz genau und ich habe manchmal meine
position gewechselt und bin jetzt einmal
nach unten gegangen um hier auch nochmal
die atmosphäre zu spüren und es ist
wirklich es sind so viele verschiedene
menschen hier ganz viele verschiedene
jung und alt und auch aus wirklich allen
nationen tatsächlich wir haben vor den
amerikanerinnen getroffen wir haben hier
ganz viele deutsche auf getroffen und
natürlich eben aus ganz europa aber eben
auch aus der ganzen welt menschen die
hier her angereist sind oder die auch
zufällig sowieso hier waren sich dann
aber hier jetzt in diese menge
angestellt haben und ihr habt ja gerade
oder ihr seht ja die ganze zeit die
bilder es sind wirklich tausende
zehntausende menschen hier nochmal mehr
als gestern gestern wurde ja der sagt
der queen erst hiernach attenborough
gebracht und da waren schon viele
menschen aber jetzt ist noch mal
wirklich das doppelte an menschen hier
gerade weil es natürlich etwas ganz
besonderes ist denn king charles der
dritte wird hier jetzt das erste mal
auch einen öffentlichen auftritt in
schottland haben es an aller erster
öffentlicher auftritt hier vor den
ganzen bürgerinnen und bürgern und das
ist für sie natürlich etwas ganz
besonderes die meisten menschen die wir
getroffen haben die freuen sich auch
jetzt richtig aufging zahlt sie sind
natürlich immer noch sehr sehr
erschüttert und sehr traurig darüber
dass kriminelle gewissen tot ist aber
dennoch sagen sie das kind als auch ein
sehr guter nachfolger ist denn er hatte
immer eine sehr starke verbindung zu der
queen und da sie sie geliebt haben so
waren die zitate von den menschen lieben
sie ihn eben auch ein freuen sich
daneben auch darauf dass er jetzt hier
zu besuch ist dass er diesen ganz
wichtigen dass er diese ganz wichtige
prozession im mit der queen jetzt von
dem palast hier in die kathedrale eben
mit begleitet und ich werde jetzt
einfach mal hier immer die leute
ansprechen
sonst
also hier sind ganz viele menschen die
eben auch eine persönliche verbindung zu
der queen haben und dann eben sagen dann
wollen wir auch einmal dabei sein dafür
nehmen wir auch eben diese fahrten mit
in kauf und ich werde vielleicht einmal
hier auch mal in die runde fragen zu den
fünf kindern
gebaut wie
youtube
[Musik]
übersetzt es nochmal einmal das mädchen
hat jetzt gesagt sie ist eben auch eine
schöne frau auch ein vorbild für viele
eben gewesen weil ich auch immer sehr
hart gearbeitet hat und das ist
natürlich auch etwas was hier dann eben
sehr gewürdigt wird bzw worauf viele in
england oder auch unsere ganzen
vereinigten königreich eben sehr sehr
stolz waren und sie können nochmal
einmal zeigen hier an der prozession
runter an der rolle herunter wie viele
menschen sind und ich kann es jetzt
gerade von hier aus meiner position
nicht sehen ob sich prinz charles king
charles
und seine ehefrau camilla und der rest
dieses zuges schon hier irgendwie in der
nähe befinden aber ich glaube man würde
es hören gestern haben sie da kann ein
weiter heran
sie haben sich bereits in bewegung
gesetzt aber ich glaube so wie das
aussieht wird es noch ein bisschen
dauern bis sie bei euch sind es geht
sehr langsam im schritttempo voran da
aber die prozession hat sich in bewegung
gesetzt können mal gemeinsam auf die
bilder schauen bewegen sich jetzt erst
langsam weg vom schloss wir haben
gesehen eine kind charles läuft hinter
dem auto aber auch prinz r dort ist
dabei und prinzessin andy erkennen sie
vielleicht nicht gleich aber die ist
militärischer uniform sie es ihren
oberst ja aber das ist sie wie viele
mitglieder des königshauses aber sie war
2002 im übrigen die
das erste weibliche mitglied des
königshauses in uniform und auch die
queen hat sich gewünscht dass ihre
tochter prinzessin die heute in uniform
begleitet also das ist die erste reihe
wenn ich es richtig erkennen hinter dem
auto
man sieht dort der fällt auf der einzige
der keine uniform trägt er ist jetzt in
der mitte des bildes das ist prinz
andrew und neben ihm dass prinzessin n
und dann
charles prinz andrew eben auffälliger
als einziger ohne uniformen er dachte
sich mehrin wurde das alles aberkannte
militärischen würden die titel und dafür
ein missbrauchsskandal in denen er
verwickelt war vor gericht kam
das war alles auch schwer zu verdauen
für die grünen er gilt ja als ihr
lieblings sohn prinz andrew dafür wurden
ihm alle militärischen ehren in auszügen
wir sehen hier genau hinter dem auto
laufen
und king charles natürlich dabei und
auch prinzessin
sie auch in militärischer uniform als
ehrenoberst
dort begleitet ihre mutter auf diesem
letzten weg in schottland jetzt verlässt
man dort das tor
diese prozession die wird von tausenden
menschen dort in edinburgh erwartet
jetzt noch mal ein anderer blick vorne
das erste auto sehen sie darin der sarg
der queen
ätherische erden da und jetzt sehen sie
ins bild laufen von rechts erst prinz
andrew nicht im militär uniform daneben
seine schwester prinzessin und dann am
rande king charles
das sieht jetzt
den sagt der queen durch edinburgh
begleiten
und dort mitten im gewühl man muss sagen
jetzt geht es langsam eben in diese
straße hinein dort vor dem schloss ist
noch relativ leer es ist natürlich
großräumig abgesperrt aber sie sehen
schon da hinten da versammeln sich viele
zahlreiche menschen der queen die letzte
ehre auf dieser reise erweisen wollen
und mitten dort in den himmel zwischen
menschen die da wirklich seit 5 uhr
sechs uhr morgens ausharren um die queen
auf wiedersehen sagen zu können ist
meine kollegin kyra ortmann hier haben
wir noch einen guten blick auf prinz
andrew im übrigen der da gerade im
sonnenlicht zu sehen war im weißen hemd
mit schwarzer krawatte eben auffällig er
ist der einzige
dort ist der rolls emmely der dort ohne
militär uniform auftaucht vor dem alles
bekannt man sieht in seiner brust noch
ein paar medaillen baumeln aber er kann
ihnen nicht und beispielsweise neben ihm
schwester prinzessin
militär und dort auftauchen kira ordnern
dort in der menschenmenge man bewegt
sich hier langsam wie gesagt im
schritttempo richtung innenstadt und
dort nicht so hier werden die menschen
dann abschied nehmen können von der
queen wenn dann kehre auch die
möglichkeit haben wirklich zum sagt zu
kommen hier sehen wir immer noch mal im
tal zu erleben prinzessin und dann
weiter im hintergrund
andrew herdman im gewühl dort tausende
menschen tiere haben wir gesehen die
dort der queen ein letztes geleit ein
letztes auf wiedersehen einen letzten
dank mit auf dem weg geben wollen was
genau ist für den heutigen tag alles
noch geplant hatte
ja wenn sie gleich in der st charles
kathedrale dort hinten heran kommen dann
wird dort noch einen gedenkgottesdienst
stattfinden und dann ist es ja so dass
der sarg der queen dort eben öffentlich
aufbewahrt wird und die menschen die
hier stehen werden sich wahrscheinlich
zumindest ein ganz ganz großer teil
davon dann in einer schlange dort
anstellen um dann auch in der kathedrale
noch mal ganz persönlich abschied von
der queen zu nehmen sie dürfen an dem
sarg lang gehen da gibt es natürlich
ganz viele sicherheitsvorkehrungen es
darf natürlich nicht viel mitgenommen
werden man darf zum beispiel nur eine
kleine tasche mitnehmen man darf nicht
mal wasserflaschen mitnehmen die durch
die man nicht durchblicken kann dass es
dürfen nur durchsichtige wasserflaschen
sein die man eben mit in die kathedrale
nimmt und das sind natürlich alles die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen die für so ein
großes event getroffen werden müssen das
gleiche wird übrigens auch ab mittwoch
noch einmal in london stattfinden und
zwar wird die queen ja dort dann auf
einer noch größeren prozession eben
durch ganz london von buckingham palace
ins westminster abbey getragen und ab
dort wird sie dann für viereinhalb tage
auch noch mal dort eben in dem sarg
liegen und für die öffentlichkeit
zugänglich sein dass man dort eben noch
mal persönlich abschied nehmen kann und
auch dort werde neben tausende 10.000
wahrscheinlich sogar insgesamt millionen
menschen erwartet die noch mal extra für
dieses event nach london pilgern um dann
eben bei diesem ganzen historischen tag
wirklich dabei zu sein wir haben ganz
viele menschen die hier in dieser
schlange stehen heute gesagt dieser tag
wirklich in die geschichtsbücher hier
eingehen wenn nicht sogar in ganz europa
oder wenn nicht sogar auf der ganzen
welt weil das ist natürlich das erste
mal dass die menschen diesem sagt dann
jetzt eben ganz nahe kommen können und
dieses event muss man ja fast schon
sagen was es hier ist das gab es ja auch
eben seit 70 jahren nicht mehr weil seit
70 jahren gab es eben queen elizabeth
die zweite und davor gab es eben ja
schon lange keinen kleinen königs
wechseln bzw keinen regierungswechsel
hier und wir sagen gerade neben wir noch
menschen stühle raus damit sie noch
einen besseren blick gleich auf die neue
meiler haben auf den moment wenn daneben
ja der sack hier lang getragen wird und
ja dadurch dass gerade schon gesagt
viele menschen sind seit heute morgen da
ich habe vorhin einige getroffen die
sogar seit gestern abend schon angereist
sind um hier daneben dabei zu sein um
ganz vorne in der ersten reihe
bestenfalls einen platz einzunehmen und
was ich noch ganz interessant fand viele
menschen haben auch ihre hunde
mitgebracht hierher was man ja erst mal
vielleicht ein bisschen kritisieren
könnte weil so viele menschen hier auf
einem haufen und dann die runde
dazwischen aber die menschen haben eben
gesagt die queen hat ja ihre hunde so
geliebt sie hatte er selber 30 hobbys
oder um die dreißig cookies und deswegen
haben sie gesagt sie wollen auch ein par
runde oder ihre hunde mittel her bringen
weil sie sich sicher sind dass die queen
das auch richtig schön gefunden hätte
wenn eben viele tiere auch dabei sind
weil sie ja ebenso eine tierliebhaberin
auch war
absolute corgi liebe hunde lieber und
während wir hier sprechen sieht man wie
die prozession ehre zitiere ich weiß
nicht ob du bei dir ne ecke schon was
erkennen kannst was spürbar selbst hier
ist im studio ist wie still alle
teilnehmer dieser prozession sind wenn
der sack vorbeifährt absolute stille
dort an dach dort sagen wir diese live
bilder auch mal auf
dass der letzte weg der queen in
schottland ihrem gerieten schottland
also dort ist ja auch gestorben
aufschluss moral sondern sie immer die
sommerfrische verbracht traditionell
immer bis oktober war sie dort sie jetzt
eben am vergangenen freitag plötzlich
starb die queen auf ihrem letzten weg
dort 24 stunden dort wird der sarg noch
einmal seinen platz finden in der
kathedrale dort in edinburgh damit die
menschen sich verabschieden können und
hier sehen wir jetzt ganz genau
hinschauen sehen sie einen mann der
zweite von rechts in ihrem bildschirm
prinz angel the book of york so darf man
ihn noch nennen alle militärischen ehren
wurden ihm aberkannt nachdem er in einen
missbrauchsskandal
offenbar verwickelt war
militärischen ehren ihm der im volk
antwort diente wurden ihm aberkannt der
sarg wird begleitet natürlich von king
charles das cert er läuft hinter dem
sarg her hatte heute schon einen
bewegenden tag das parlament seien für
ihn god save the king heißt es jetzt und
da sahen wir prinzessin erst mal noch
mit tränen in den augen tränen
sicherlich für seine geliebte
verstorbene mutter aber sicherlich auch
tränen der überwältigung angesichts
dieses großen amt ist dieser großen
verantwortung die er der antritt jetzt
begleitet er den sarg seiner mutter der
sagt der queen dort in diesem auto
[Applaus]
und man hörte ein paar gut für den
menschen dort in edinburgh die seit
stunden ausharren und der queen ein
letztes dankeschön ein letztes geleit es
auf wiedersehen entgegen zu rufen
die prozessionen die jetzt dort durch
die stadt gehen wird eine halbe stunde
lang
viele versuchen ein foto von einem auto
zu machen
und auch einen blick zu erhaschen auf
king charles
prinz charles solange in dieser rolle
als prinz charles
und dann das die plötzliche veränderung
dieser welt hier sehen wir von hinten
auf der rechten seite mit dem roten band
den wir king charles daneben sehen wir
prinzessin in seinem weißen bary auf dem
kopf und dann sehen sie prinz andrew die
kinder also von queen elizabeth der
zweite viele hatten gehofft dass es doch
noch mal auch zu dieser gelegenheit
einen auftritt gibt der wert vor also
von william und kate und megan und harry
ganz überraschend an die sich am
wochenende gezeigt wo ja auf eine
initiative von prinz william hin
hier noch einmal die blumen angeschaut
ein auftritt zu führt viele royale fans
hatten die hoffnung dass auch diese
prozession in edinburgh dafür noch mal
die gelegenheit bietet dennoch es war
relativ schnell klar nur die kinder der
queen werden daran teilnehmen
in dieser letzten prozession durch
schottland durch edinburgh
sind wir hier die der wagen mit dem
sagte green durch die stadt zieht und
mittendrin ist kira ordnern meine
kollegin sabina ist die präzession jetzt
bei dir könnt ihr schon erkennen die
prozession euch langsam nähert alle sind
ja darauf versessen einen letzten blick
auf den sarg der queen zu bekommen ihr
die letzte ehre zu erweisen aber
natürlich auch im neuen könig einmal in
die augen zu schauen
ich habe gerade mit einem ordner
gesprochen und er meinte es dauert noch
ungefähr fünf minuten bis sie hier
hinter uns sind und er meinte aber auch
direkt zu mir sie werden es merken
sobald sich der sack genährt denn im
moment man hört ist ja noch die leute
unterhalten sich es ist eine ganz
normale atmosphäre aber eben schon eine
gespannte aber er sagte dann auch sobald
sich der sack nähert wird es still sein
die menschen könnten ja auch jubeln
beziehungsweise das hatte ich persönlich
tatsächlich erst gedacht dass sie dem
neuen könig zu jubeln dass sie
vielleicht auch noch mal im team sagt zu
jubeln aber tatsächlich verhalten sich
die menschen hier eher ruhig und eher
andächtig weil es ja tatsächlich hier
auch nicht um den neuen könig geht
sondern eben darum der queen in dem sack
noch mal eine letzte ehre zu erweisen
sich von der queen zu verabschieden und
deswegen ist es tatsächlich immer ein
wirklicher gänsehautmoment gestern als
der sarg ich hier von balmoral castle je
nach edinburgh gefahren wurde waren wir
auch schon dabei da waren ja auch schon
wirklich zehntausende menschen hier
nicht ganz so viele wie heute wir heute
natürlich noch mal ein etwas größeres
event hier drum herum stattfindet mit
dem gottesdienst und eben das überhaupt
king charles sitzt dabei ist aber auch
gestern war es schon wirklich so dass
ein kurzer die luft weggeblieben ist als
eben dieser sagt dann hier gefahren
wurde durch diese rolle weil das eben
für gerade auch die schotten eben ein
ganz ganz besonderer moment ist viele
haben mir gesagt natürlich ist es
tragisch ist die queen überhaupt
gestorben ist darüber muss man gar nicht
sprechen aber es ist auch irgendwie was
besonderes dass sie eben in balmoral
castle dort gestorben ist ihrem
lieblings 70 vertriebs von gesagt sie
hat dort jeden sommer urlaub gemacht
über mehrere monate hat dort grillpartys
und bieten den partys geschmissen und
hat ja dort tatsächlich auch ihren prinz
philip richtig lieben gelernt ich habe
einen journalisten getroffen der dann
sagte dort in balmoral castle ist ihr
herz richtig aufgeblüht damals als sie
dort zu viel zeit mit prinz philip
verbracht hat und dort hat es dann jetzt
eben auch final aufgehört zu schlagen
das fand ich eine ganz passende anekdote
dahin zu wissen eben was für eine
besondere bedeutung dieses stoffs
vellmar für die queen eben hatte aber
auch natürlich der palast hier in
edinburgh hat eine ganz besondere
bedeutung hier kann sie natürlich er
immer her zum arbeiten aber dennoch war
das natürlich der hauptsitz der
königlichen familie dieser palace of
holyroodhouse denn dort das ist eben das
einzige große königsschloss was inmitten
einer stadt ist hier in schottland wo
eben menschen auch ja sonst im
besichtigung machen konnten und so
weiter und deswegen ist es gerade
besonders auch für die schotten dass die
queen jetzt ihre letzte route durch
schottland machen kann wäre sie zum
beispiel nämlich in london gestorben
wäre das event oder ich hätte das
zumindest in frage gestanden ob sie noch
einmal ihre route durch schottland macht
und so konnten sich oder hatten jetzt
die menschen hier in schottland eben
auch die möglichkeit sich noch mal zu
verabschieden und wir haben ja die
bilder aus den letzten tagen gesehen als
ich hier durch schottland gereist ist
diese ganze route über sechs stunden
lang ist er gereist dort standen so
viele menschen dort ist in wurde zwar
untersagt dass sie nicht oder sie
sollten nicht unbedingt mit blumen
werfen weil das ist natürlich ein auto
das dort fährt das kann natürlich auch
gefährlich werden aber viele menschen
haben in sachen gebastelt und sie
zumindest an die route gelegt und soeben
ihrer queen das letzte mal im gedenkt
gedacht und auch hier an der straße wo
wir jetzt gerade stehen haben zwar die
leute jetzt nicht viele blumen
mitgebrachten blumen haben sie vor allen
dingen vor der kirche und vor dem palast
niedergelegt aber ich sehe immer wieder
menschen die zb eine flagge hissen oder
die zum beispiel sich kleine anstecker
an die brust gesteckt haben um nochmal
zu zeigen wie besonders eben dieser
moment ist und wir haben es ja gerade
schon seit dieser moment hier wird
tatsächlich in die geschichtsbücher
mindestens hier im vereinten königreich
eingehen so viele menschen hier an einem
ort und das nach dieser ganzen zeit so
nach corona und so weiter wo sowas ja
auch alles nicht möglich war jetzt sind
die menschen hier draußen und haben
immerhin gesagt jetzt haben sie immerhin
die möglichkeit was sie dann auch
wirklich als positiv entdecken und ein
kleines detail noch zu gestern als
nämlich der sarg hierher gefahren ist
eigentlich sollte es den ganzen
nachmittag regnet es hat aber den ganzen
nachmittag die sonne geschienen und erst
als der sarg in den palast getroffen ist
dann fing es an zu regnen und viele
menschen ich heute getroffen habe sagte
neben das war auch ein schicksalsschlag
bzw das war ihrem schicksal dass das
wetter so gut mitgespielt hat und man
sieht es heute das wetter hier ist so
schön das kennt man ja fast gar nicht so
hier aus england beziehungsweise
schottland und ja viele der engländer
bzw schott länder sind da tatsächlich
auch ein bisschen abergläubisch und
sagen dieser besonderen moment der ist
eben der cream gewidmet und der ist den
menschen hier gewidmet die hier eben
noch mal abschied nehmen wollen und
deswegen scheint die sonne wie die
beiden regenbogen die über den
buckingham palace erschienen irgendwie
gibt es wetter so scheint es den royalen
fans zeichen kira ortmann erfolg gerade
live die prozession fertig erdenbürger
die queen dort auf ihrem letzten weg in
schottland schauen wir uns noch einmal
gemeinsam die live bilder an den wenigen
minuten kira gebaut wenn die
prozessionen bei dir dann ist in wenigen
minuten ist es soweit schauen wir noch
mal live bilder rein hier sehen wir von
links king charles prinzessinnen
prinzessin ende und dann im unteren
bildrand verschwindet der gerade ins
edward also alle vier kinder der queen
begleiten ihre mutter auf dem letzten
weg auf dieser prozession durch
edinburgh schottland ein besonderer ort
für sie in baumreihe verbrachte sie
immer die sommerfrische über bis oktober
war die queen dort auch gerne mit prinz
philip gemeinsame ausritte barbecues ein
echtes landleben in unbeschwertheit
konnte sie dort führen und dort in
diesem herzens ort ist sie dann auch
verstorben ihr leichnam ist durch ihr
sarg ist durch das land gereist immer an
ihrer seite im übrigen prinzessin ihre
wohl engste vertraute ihre tochter die
sie dort auch in militärischer uniform
sehen die ihrer mutter in den letzten
stunden ihres lebens nicht eine minute
von der seite wich kann man schon sagen
in charles läuft natürlich hinter dem
sarg der mutter her
und ganz hinten sehen sie dann auch ans
ende der welt ein bisschen aus der rolle
dort er der einzige der nicht in uniform
ist ihm wurden die militärischen ehren
würden aberkannt nachdem
missbrauchs skandal in denen er offenbar
für wirklich vor wurde wird die wir
salutschüsse
hallen dort durch die stadt einen durch
drei salutschüsse zu ehren der queen
absolute stille dort
keiner jubeln auch dem neuen könig wird
nicht zu jubeln zu groß ist die er
anbietet
sagt der queen für die verstorbene queen
die dort ihre letzte reise durch
schottland antritt die menschen können
jetzt abschied nehmen es geht von
hollywood haus jetzt richtung sein james
geräte und dort wird der sarg für 24
stunden
öffentlichkeit
zugänglich sein in london wird das auch
noch mal der fall sein dann richtet man
sich bereits darauf eine acht kilometer
lange schlangen geben könnte mit bis zu
20 stunden wartezeit
der sagte viele jetzt
in dem wagen quer durch edinburgh fährt
im übrigen geschmückt mit weißen blumen
haben wir eben gesehen als der sarg
verladen wurde ins auto mit rosen mit
freesien chrysanthemen und auch mit
rosmarin von schloss balmoral
ihrem schloss auf dem
königin elizabeth ii die zweite
verstorben war ganz plötzlich am
dienstag vergangener woche konnte sie
noch einen termin wahrnehmen mittelstraß
mit liszts der neuen premierministerin
von großbritannien und dann ging alles
ganz schnell der palast gab eine
mitteilung heraus der queen gehe sich
gute ärzte würden sie beobachten und
noch am selben tag verstarb sie dann
auch zum ende der woche am dienstag
wirkte sie noch zwar gebrechlich und alt
96 jahre wurde sie als 70 jahre hat sie
auf dem thron verbracht und jetzt
versammelt man sich dort in schotten
schüsse neu zu ihren ehren
die prozessionen durch etwa durch
schottland die queen wird auf ihrem
letzten weg begleitet von ihren vier
kindern die hinter den sack herlaufen
absolute stille dort lassen wir das mal
auf uns wirken absolute stille von
zehntausenden menschen
denn hier die rhb zu machen
wir sehen dort hinter dem auto jetzt
kann man das ganz gut erkennen
von rechts erst prinz edward und daneben
das sieht man der fels optisch ein
bisschen aus der rolle
wenn du
geliebter sohn von der queen aber
das sind um gnade gefallen hier ein
weiterer
während sich die prozession jetzt sagen
sie
trainiert dort wird er sagt für 24
stunden aufgebaut damit die schotten und
schotten abschied nehmen können von
ihrer queen queen elizabeth der zweite
hier sehen wir mal das auto ganz nahe
jetzt vorbeifahren
eine glasfront der mit der sag auch
sichtbar ist damit die menschen
zehntausender stehenden sagt hier sehen
wir die blumen weiße rosen weiße
chrysanthemen weiße frisieren aber auch
duftender rosmarin von schluss bewahren
und hier sehen wir die kinder der queen
am unteren bildrand prinzessin sehen sie
prinz andrew neben ihm
prinzessinnen und daneben king charles
das
so lange kannten ihn als prinz charles
und jetzt jetzt noch sehr große
fußstapfen von verabschiedete sich auch
heute noch einmal vor dem parlament mit
bewegenden worten von seiner geliebten
nach prinz harry hat heute nochmal eine
mitteilung gemacht sich bei grey's
anatomy
quasi sich bei uns bedankt für alles
auch noch mal dafür bedankt wie sehr sie
medien in der familie willkommen hieß
das hat er extra nochmal erwähnt in
dieser erklärung fiel am gehofft dass
möglicherweise prinz r imagine oder
zumindest william und kate jetzt auch
bei diesem termin in edinburgh dabei
sind aber die fed vor so werden sie
genannt so wurden sogenannte als sie
sich alle noch vertrugen sind in london
dort steht noch vieles in den kommenden
tagen auf dem programm
19 september dann die beerdigung von
queen elizabeth ii es müsste sich die
prozession meiner kollegin kyra ortmann
nähern dort wollen wir jetzt auch
hingehen kira harz mit tausenden
menschen dort aus die seit den frühen
morgenstunden kira
diesen blick dieses auf wiedersehen
jetzt ist ja auch bei euch hier ich
glaube es ist schwierig über die ersten
sechs ersehen direkt bei uns hinter uns
genau das sagt es direkt hier jetzt
[Musik]
und man sieht es tatsächlich hier die
atmosphäre die menschen sind tatsächlich
ganz ruhig deswegen rede ich jetzt auch
ein bisschen leiser viele haben
natürlich ihre handys gezückt und ich
werde die kamera noch mal ein bisschen
drehen
kira ortmann jetzt gerade sind wir hier
hier von dir live die bilder du bist nur
wenige meter entfernt
[Applaus]
absolute stille ja und ich habe ich
wirklich sagen
genau ich muss wirklich sagen die
menschengruppe aber gucken dass wir hier
tun haben aber die menschen sind alle
sehr sehr ruhig verhalten sich hier sehr
sehr ruhig ich hätte ja gedacht dass die
menschen dem sack auch noch mehr zu
trinken oder zu jubeln aber tatsächlich
sind wirklich alle einfach ganz ruhig
alle haben ihre handys gezückt hinter
mir und
gedenken jetzt einfach
genießen tatsächlicher
geschichtsträchtigen moment hier
lassen wir das mal ein bisschen auf uns
wirken wenn man muss wirklich sagen kira
ist kaum etwas zu hören absolute stille
im hintergrund es sind zehntausende
menschen dort auf der straße
und jetzt sehen wir hier live prozession
vorbei ziehen hier auch im linken bild
noch mal einen blick auf den sarg von
queen elizabeth der zweite
und dahinter
hier sehen sie den charts und wird unter
uns
[Applaus]
einmal mit sorge
wer tatsächlich ist der sack hier jetzt
gerade lang gefahren und ich versuche
die kamera gehört auch ein bisschen
verhalten ist zugleich wenn es ein
bisschen wackeln aber die menschen sind
jetzt hier gerade angefangen zu
klatschen nachdem sie erst alle ganz
ganz ruhig waren hier an diesem punkt
fangen die menschen jetzt an zu
klatschen der queen quasi noch einmal
zujubeln dann doch nachdem sie denn
jedoch erst sehr sehr still waren und
jetzt gleich jeden moment kommt die
queen dort also der sagt der queen dort
an der kathedrale an
da hinten sieht man die jetzt auch von
deiner kamera perspektive aus der hinten
im hintergrund das ist das gebäude das
jetzt
angesteuert wird dies seien kredite die
hauptkirche der church of scotland
jedes hier diese royal mile entlang
bemerkenswert absolute stille hier sieht
man hinter dem auto sieht man gut ins
gesicht gerade von prinzessin
und hier geht's hin
zahlreiche menschen dort auf der straße
prinzessin andy tochter der queen
vielseitigkeitsreiterin sie teilt mit
ihrer mutter die liebe für pferde und
war wirklich jede minute in den
vergangenen tagen an der seite ihrer
mutter dazu begleitet bis zum letzten
atemzug warm todes bett und hat aber
auch davor die wochen davor viel zeit
mit ihr verbracht war in schottlands die
auch prinz charles wir damals noch hieß
zum zeitpunkt des todes in schottland
war
und jetzt die prozession das letzte
geleit für die königin dort in edinburgh
in schottland und mittendrin ist meine
kollegin kyra ortmann mit vielen
menschen die nur eines heute zum zähler
die sich frei genommen haben nicht zur
arbeit gegangen sind urlaub eingereicht
haben um der queen einmal ein letztes
geleit eine letzten respekt zu zeigen
ganz genau und hinter mir löst sich
jetzt diese menschenmenge schon ein
bisschen denn die menschen ja entweder
müssen tatsächlich videos gerade gesagt
dass zum beispiel zurück zur arbeit oder
daneben können ja hier dann auch nicht
mehr viel sehen und picardie mann aus
deutschland getroffen sie extra
angereist hierher oder wie
also ich bin zum ersten mal in
schottland und wollte hier in edinburgh
natürlich kommen das sei so einfach
liegen lassen das ist klar ich komme aus
deutschland aus sachsen-anhalt naumburg
und
ich sag mal die atmosphäre die wollte
ich heute hier natürlich mitnehmen und
ja natürlich auch talk-queen die soviel
dienst hat auch ein bisschen respekt
johann der stelle nochmal mit sollen wir
haben sie das hier gerne wahrgenommen
ich habe gesagt es war es total still
here und als die prozessionen dann ja
langsam an uns vorbei weil sich dann
hier nur wenige meter von mir entfernt
haben die leute rannten zu klatschen
also ich hatte erst gedacht dass die
menschenmenge richtig applaus spendet
wenn die queen ihr vorbeigefahren aber
es war eine absolute totenstille und
erst danach fing man verhalten mit
applaus an das habe ich nicht erwartet
ich genauso wenig aber dennoch da ist ja
irgendwie so ein wirklicher
gänsehautmoment fand ich wäre ihnen
diesen ganz besonderen moment auch wenn
wir in deutschland vielleicht gar nicht
so diesen direkten bezug zu queen oder
zur königlichen familie haben sondern
eher dass er als ein bisschen von außen
gesehen wie sehen sie das ja das ist
richtig trotzdem sie hat viele sachen
man grundsätzlich auch schon ganz europa
und ich sage mal auch über sieben
jahrzehnte das so konstant durchzuziehen
das ist schon sehr sehr gut vielen dank
erstmal der wünsche ihnen einen schönen
tag dankeschön ja und wir werden jetzt
gleich mal auch in richtung der
kathedrale gehen denn dort wird ja jetzt
gleich der gottesdienst dann stattfinden
wo dann ja auch king charles ii drittel
noch mal eine rede halten wird und noch
mal ja seine mutter würdigen wird und ab
dann ist er sagt der queen für die
öffentlichkeit zugänglich deswegen
glaube ich auch dass viele menschen die
jetzt hinter mir an der straße standen
sich jetzt schon auf den weg machen eben
zu der kathedrale um natürlich einmal
den gottesdiensten an auch mit zu
erleben zumindest von so nah dran wie
möglich aber dann sich auch eben bei der
schlange an zu stellen die dann eben in
die kathedrale führt damit sie dann auch
noch mal einen blick einen ganz
persönlichen blick eben auf den sarg
werfen können
ihren vielen herzlichen dank macht sich
mal auf richtungen kathedrale ich denke
mal es wird eine lange schlange sein
sind denn alle möglichen menschen
überhaupt zählt weil sie erlaubt dass
man jetzt auch schon am gottesdienst
teilnimmt wird er irgendwo übertragen
wir können in jeder weltbild leist
natürlich übertragen aber nicht jeder
schotte hatte gerade bild live zur
verfügung dort in den straßen von
edinburgh also wer wird da alles
teilnehmen
also tatsächlich ist auf den auf dem
platz der kirche dort ist auch schon
einiges aufgebaut so dass eben so viele
menschen wie möglich daran teilnehmen
können aber dennoch man sieht es hier
die straße ist jetzt auch nicht so breit
dass dort eben jetzt alle hingehen
können um diesen gottesdienst damit zu
erleben aber auch freund schon gesehen
dass sich viele leute in den papst
treffen um dann tatsächlich dort ja
quasi kleines public viewing zu machen
was ja auch irgendwo ungewöhnlich ist
dass man eben ein gottesdienst in einem
pub cook aber wie gesagt dieser moment
ist so historisch so besonders für diese
menschen hier dass sie eben das
natürlich auch in gemütlicher atmosphäre
damit erleben möchten bevor sie sich
dann eben anstellen um selber noch mal
in die kirche gehen zu können das haben
damit tatsächlich sehr sehr viele leute
frau die familie die ich hier gerade
getroffen habe die frau mit ihren fünf
kindern hat gesagt sie will unbedingt
selber noch einmal in die kathedrale
gehen um dann selber noch mal einen ganz
persönlichen abschied von der queen
nehmen zu können und dass man sie
tatsächlich anreist auch mit seinen
kindern oder eben auch auf der anderen
seite viele ältere menschen die sich
hier noch mal her begeben haben in diese
riesen menschenmenge die aber dann
gesagt haben das ist für mich so ein
besonderer moment in wahrheit so lange
unserem land gedient das ist tatsächlich
ja eine ganz besondere atmosphäre hier
insgesamt ihrer ordnen vielen herzlichen
lang und werden du sprichst gängelei
verfolgen wir die prozession jetzt zu
einem ende kommt man ist dort anders als
kathedrale auch angekommen dass uns
einmal die bilder gemeinsame anschauen
dort jetzt also das ziel dieser
prozession erreicht zehntausende
menschen in edinburgh in schottland
haben der queen
letztes geleit gegeben haben sich auf
den strassen versammelt
und jetzt ist man angekommen dort
drinnen in der sanchez kapitel in der
high court of edinburgh wird es gleich
ein
gedenkgottesdienst eben auch king
charles wird dort noch einmal sprechen
heute hatte im parlament gesprochen und
als god save the king zum ersten mal
gespielt wurde für ihn hat er tränen in
den augen erst ein schwerer gang für ihn
eher sarg seiner sehr geliebten mutter
wird jetzt dort in die kathedrale
nein gebracht
es rückt 500 meter nur von edinburgh
castle entfernt
der sarg geschmückt
konnte man vor ein bisschen erkenne mit
weißen blüten mit rosen mit freesien mit
chrysanthemen aber auch mit duftenden
rosmarin von schloss balmoral der orts
in schottland an dem die queen
verstorben ist
sehr plötzlich im hohen alter von 96
jahren 70 jahre war 77 jahre weil sie
queen elizabeth die zweite
und jetzt hier nimm schottland von ihr
abschied ihre vier kinder sind dabei
ging charles das sind natürlich neu im
amt große würde große fußstapfen
prinzessin ist natürlich dabei ihre
tochter mit der sie so viel verbindet
vor allem die liebe zum reitsport und
edward ist dabei
auch er gilt wie ein stiller
lieblingssohn der green natürlich
prinzessin
und auch prinz andrew er ist hier auf
diesen live bildern wenn sie immer
wieder sehen als einziger zu erkennen
der nicht eine militärische uniform
trägt den boden alle militärischen
ehren aberkannte beim einem
missbrauchsskandal verwickelt und das
war die konsequenz davon und vor der
kathedrale sieht man uns adwords frau
sophie und auch kamelen wir gesehen mit
einem großen schwarzen hut schon immer
ob die kamera der leitbilder der gleich
nochmal genauer dran geht jetzt moment
wird der sarg entladen und
dann anschließend nissan jazz festival
zu bringen dort dann ein großer
gedenkgottesdienst zu ehren lag bei ihm
gesagt ich jetzt gerade vorsichtig
aus dem auto gehoben
absolute stille dort in edinburgh auf
beide positionen vielleicht mal
zaghafter applaus der respekt ausdrücken
sollte und dank
und hier sieht man jetzt den sarg von
queen elizabeth der zweite
lange wird so etwas natürlich geprobt
auch jetzt schon wird für die
beerdigungen geprobt
natürlich dass hier nichts schiefgehen
muss alles ganz genau nach protokoll
ablaufen ganz wichtiger moment in
historischer moment und
jetzt bewegt man sich langsam dort
eingang der sanchez
der sagte königin elizabeth der zweite
70 jahren als sie auf dem thron 70 jahre
als ihrem volk gedient
glückliche jahre als erlebt auch
schwierige jahres erlebt der tod von
lady di das brennen von buckingham
palast der streit zuletzt zwischen ihren
enkelkindern prinz harry und prinz
william
der tod ihres geliebten mannes prinz
philip im vergangenen jahr ihre kurven
erkrankungen im februar besonders die
letzten monate an schwierige monate für
queen elizabeth hier sehen wir im sack
weiße blüten sehen sie hier sind weiße
rosen weiße freesien weiße chrysanthemen
auch duftende kräuter dort aus den
gärten von schloss balmoral rosmarin
dort zwischen den blüten das also
schmückt ihren sarg
der jetzt gerade vorsichtig
die treppen der song gefällt will hinauf
getragen wird
dort wird er aufgebaut
und dort wird gleich ein gottesdienst
stattfinden king charles ist natürlich
vor ort und hier sehen sie auf der
linken bild seite mit einem großen hut
den sie festhält sehen sie camilla und
dahinter
sophie von wessex die frau von prinz
edward und
hier
sehen wir ja wieder sagt der queen
hineingebracht wird in die kathedrale
jetzt sehen sie hier gleich am rechten
bildrand king charles befüllt
und hinter ihm und sie gesehen und
prinzessinnen jetzt startet hier gleich
der gedenkgottesdienst der gedenk
gottesdienst bei dem der eine oder
andere auch gehofft hat dass vielleicht
doch noch mal prinz william und seine
kate und prinz harry und megan einen
auftritt haben werden viele
wünschen sich dass die trauer diese
familie die royale familie dann doch
wieder ein bisschen vereint dass die
zerstrittenen brüder wieder näher
zusammenrücken geeint in dieser trauer
um ihre gewichtung
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber hallo
und jetzt werden dort der
gedenkgottesdienst beginn schauen wir
auf ein bild es ein bisschen hoffnung
gemacht hat allen royalen fans denn wir
haben sie tatsächlich vereint gesehen
die fed vor es bleibt zu hoffen dass
dieser streit endlich mal beigelegt wird
am wochenende kam also wirklich william
und harry zum ersten mal öffentlich
zusammen kate und megan sie alle der fed
vorhat sich dort bedankt für die
anteilnahme die fed vor sind also wieder
vereint
dieser befehl kam von ganz oben für
einen moment waren die fantastic four
wieder vereint seite an seite in trauer
verbunden zeigten sich william und kate
jetzt prinz und prinzessin von wales mit
prinz harry und herzogin medien am
wochenende vor dem schloss windsor um
der queen ihrer großmutter zu gedenken
mehr als 40 minuten verbrachten sie mit
den menschen spendeten trost namen
blumen entgegen und ehrten die crew
es ist das erste mal seit über zwei
jahren dass die vier zusammen in der
öffentlichkeit zu sehen sind und auch
wenn der anlass tief traurig ist so
zeigen diese bilder was sich royal fans
seit jahren sehnlichst wünschen den
frieden zwischen den zwei brüdern
es ist total überraschend harry und
megan hier zu sehen es ist schön sie
alle zusammen zu sehen
ich denke es zieht einen schlussstrich
unter das was passiert ist auch aus
historischer sicht und es zeigt den
großen zusammenhalt der royalen familie
es war wunderschön dass sie heute zu
sehen waren
ich denke sie werden einfach alles unter
den teppich kehren und einfach wieder
brüder sein
doch wie kam es zu der lang erwarteten
wiedervereinigung vielleicht sogar einer
ersten versöhnung
britischen medien zufolge sollen sie
dafür verantwortlich sein prinz william
und könig charles
william soll harry und megan persönlich
eingeladen haben gemeinsam mit ihm und
kate zu trauern eine geste ein kleines
friedensangebot dass harry und merken
wohl angenommen haben doch freiwillig
soll diese einladung nicht ausgesprochen
worden sein charles william angerufen
und ein machtwort gesprochen haben er
habe verlangt dass seine zerstrittenen
söhne ihren zwist nach dem tod der
großmutter wenigstens in der
öffentlichkeit beilegen und das mit
erfolg wie diese bilder beweisen
vielleicht bringt die gemeinsame trauer
die brüder auch in zukunft wieder näher
zusammen queen elizabeth hätte sich das
jedenfalls sehr gewünscht
und ein weiteres kleines signal gab es
heute von prinz harry als ein statement
veröffentlicht in dem er das leben
seiner großmutter der majestät der
königin feiert und ihren verlust
betrauert und in dem er auch schreibt er
dankt ihr für immer forever great for
any schreibt er darin also ich bin die
romy für immer dankbar hat auch nochmal
erwähnt wie dankbar ist dass sie meckern
so sehr in die familie aufgenommen hat
und dass sie für viele menschen ein
kompass war in ihrem engagement
wir schauen weiter live nach edinburgh
dort meine kollegin kyra ortmann kira
wie groß ist die hoffnung der menschen
ist die rolfs emily sich in der trauer
mehr ein besonders was die fed vor
betrifft besonders was prinz harry und
sein bruder prinz william und kate
mccann
die hoffnung ist tatsächlich sehr groß
also ich glaube jeder mit dem ich
gesprochen habe alle waren sehr froh
über diese bilder die uns daraus london
erreicht haben vom schloss windsor dort
als die brüder dann eben mit den beiden
frauen zusammen sich die blumen das
blumenmeer dort vor ort angeschaut haben
denn die menschen die fanden es alle
natürlich sehr sehr traurig dass eben
william und harry sich ja irgendwie so
auseinander gelebt haben zerstritten
haben sagt man ja und die hoffnung ist
tatsächlich einfach sehr sehr groß dass
es jetzt besser wird dass sie jetzt
öfters auch wieder zusammen sich zeigen
in der öffentlichkeit das war ja
prinzipiell so wie wir es gehört bzw
dann muss ich mir noch ein bisschen
gewöhnen das war king charles eben sehr
sehr wichtig dass die vier dort auch
diesen öffentlichen auftritt gemeinsam
machen damit sie eben auch vielleicht
ein zeichen setzen damit sie das zeichen
setzen dass sie eine geschlossene
familie sind dass sie eine ansicht
glückliche familie sind die tatsächlich
jetzt in zeiten der trauer noch mal
wieder mehr zusammenwachsen und das hört
man ja tatsächlich eben aus vielen
familiengeschichten gerade wenn so etwas
passiert dass man dann eben doch wieder
zusammenwächst und ja auch die schotten
hier auch wenn sie endlich ein bisschen
weiter wächst und als die menschen in
london von der royalen familie aber auch
sie hoffen sehr dass da eben jetzt ja
die der besserung herrscht und
tatsächlich hatten auch viele gehofft
dass prinz william und prinz harry heute
auch hier dabei sind bei diesen
besonderen zug hierdurch euro das waren
sie nicht aber tatsächlich am mittwoch
bei der großen prozession die durch
london dann gehen wird vom buckingham
palace und westminster abbey dort wird
dann die gesamte königliche familie mit
dabei sein und mit gehen und sich dann
eben genau so wie hier heute king
charles und auch prinz andrew und
prinzessinnen die gemeinsam hier daneben
lang gegangen sind so wird es dann eben
am mittwoch durch london seien mit noch
mal viel viel mehr leute da sind wir
natürlich auch dabei werden wieder live
und vor ort bericht und dann natürlich
auch einen genauen blick dahin werfen
wie sich william und harry gegenseitig
unterstützen wie sie gegenseitig
miteinander agieren und natürlich auch
wie megan und kämpfen sich da
gegenseitig bzw würde behandeln lassen
natürlich die spannende frage kira
ordnend für uns in edinburgh die trauer
um die queen jetzt die royale familie
wieder zusammenführen wird vor allem die
zerstrittenen brüder wieder mehr einen
wird das vor allem der wunsch von king
charles das wird aber natürlich auch der
wunsch der verstorbenen queen
[Musik]